foreign
project
let's tell Amazon and MGM very loudly
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so Brad Wright the co-creator and really
the main man in my opinion behind most
of Target
and
he hasn't been contacted by MGM now I
have messaged Brad Wright to ask him
again most recently just a couple of
days ago whether he has added in contact
with MGM at all and he sent me back just
one word nope
so
we are going to tell Amazon that MTM
exactly what we want that we want Brad
Wright involved in the new Stargate
project in some way now I have heard a
couple of rumors coming out of MGM that
actually make this campaign
more than just us voicing our opinion it
might actually make a difference but I'm
going to tell you about that in another
video for now I'm going to ask you to go
over to change.org and sign the petition
there's a link in the description
we want as many names and that petition
as we can possibly get and once we get a
good few thousand I will send that to
Amazon telling them loud and clear
that Stargate fans or skaters really
really want Brad right involved
now before I tell you about the rumor in
the next video let me just talk quickly
about why do we want Brad right involved
if you think about the rings of power in
the last few years one of the main
complaints that Tolkien that rings to
the Lord of the Rings fans had is that
the new makers didn't seem to understand
Lord of the Rings they didn't seem to
understand the totalism we want somebody
involved in Stargate that understands
Stargate we do not want an Alex kurtzen
we want somebody more Victorious a
Stargate fan somebody that understands
it somebody that loves it somebody that
knows it inside and out and that is and
always will be Brad Wright now he
doesn't have to show run for me he could
just come in and consult he could come
as an executive producer he could come
in in really any role they've been but
just putting his name on the new project
will make us fans a lot more relaxed
about the possibility of the Stargate
franchise returning so guys get to the
description go and have a look sign the
petition as quickly as you can share it
with all your friends put it out there
you don't have to share this video if
you don't want to it is not about
advertising Sidetrack this is about to
get in Brad Ray on the ticket for the
new Stargate franchise so share the
petition everywhere and anywhere you can
if you are new to the channel though
like subscribe hit the Bell notification
it really helps us out you'll never miss
any of our new videos including the
video I'm going to be doing next talking
about wine this is actually a really
good idea and could actually do
something
um also go to patreon.com where you get
to see most of our videos first and for
a small contribution each month will be
the sports channel you get to see them
without the adverts
sorry if the wind's blown a little bit
but look at that view
yeah
thanks guys see you soon
[Music]